hey game pass friends there's new games
to play the ever growing game pass
library is a good problem to have but it
can be a little overwhelming besides
you're likely only playing halo and
forza anyway but in the case you're
looking for a little break here's a list
of games worth checking out even better
cloud beta is now a thing on consoles 2
bringing the ease of trying before you
download super easy and convenient so to
celebrate i made sure every game on this
list was also cloud ready
[Music]
simulators there's so many realistic
simulators on the market these days
farming simulator goat simulator curt
and davina simulator it was only a
matter of time until we got deer
simulator deer with
four e's
yeah and it's shaping up to be the most
authentic one yet because let's face it
when they're not running in front of
cars what are they really doing well
dear simulator looks to finally answer
that very question we ask ourselves
every day because
what else would a deer be doing if not
running into traffic
[Music]
we're all just a shell in some mortal
existence am i right anyway mortal shell
is on game pass it's the action rpg
that's like a love letter to from
software's souls born genre also game
pass doesn't have any souls games so
this is basically the next best thing
thankfully though it's not just a clone
but adds ideas and mechanics that make
it a fresh experience even for veteran
souls players it'll still require the yi
old precision and skill but is a bit
more forgiving than the brutal nature of
dark souls our very own phil hornshaw
liked it too he gave it an 8 out of 10
in his review so that's pretty good and
if you're new to the souls like games
well this could be a good entry point
grand theft auto san andreas okay so
yeah there's been a little controversy
surrounding rockstar's handling of the
gta the trilogy the definitive edition
but on a personal note i've been playing
quite a bit of san andreas on game pass
these past couple weeks and i'm honestly
still having a great time i haven't
really run into a whole lot of issues
yeah i'm still not really sold on the
soft doughy look its characters have
been given but there's no denying its
mechanics world and story hold up
incredibly well for a 17 year old game
san andreas also stands as the most
immersive sim of the franchise being
able to put on some pounds get super
buff have relationships improve weapon
skills and defend gang turf it's still
pretty impressive
what's always old is usually always new
again un dungeon is an action
role-playing game in the same vein as
old school action rpgs like shadowrun
torchlight and diablo you control a
herald a hero created by god and battle
through a science fiction story
involving a secret interdimensional
organization and catastrophe you can
also replace your organs like gear so
that's pretty cool
described as an interplanetary
gravity-defying journey through space
and time x01 is just downright pretty
chill it's a fairly meditative game with
minimal controls that once honed in and
mastered can become a really relaxing
journey using gravity flight and motion
to soar through some really beautiful
intergalactic vistas you'll feel like a
cool alien morphing bald disc thing in
no time and cruise through otherworldly
environments to some soothing hypnotic
tunes i've been playing this one on the
cloud and it's a really easy one to just
jump in and out of
[Music]
ah yes unpacking the game to turn a
tedious chore we must all face at some
point in our lives into something
meaningful and empathetic look i hate
packing let alone unpacking but
unpacking is a game that takes the
process of moving and unpacking your
belongings and uses it as a means to
tell an intimate story about growth and
change go through different years in a
person's life from child to teenager to
college student to full-on adulthood and
organize their personal items and their
changing environment in the process you
see what they've kept through the years
what they've part aways with and how
their tastes and interests develop along
with it or you can be like me and just
get chaotic joy out of putting where it
absolutely does not belong
non-guns a game that actually has
lots of guns it calls itself a
nihilistic action platformer roguelike a
fitting description for a game with
little skeleton dudes blasting creatures
apart in a stark and grim setting this
version the doppelganger edition is a
remastered version of the original never
previously released on consoles and
features in all new arena and local
co-op modes so lock and load in this
dire shoot em up where nothing matters
but all still too much fun
rev up your engine listen to that hull
and roar it's time to strap in and ride
into the danger zone with project
wingman this isn't your run-of-the-mill
flight simulator no this is a
no-holds-barred combat flight action
game that'll have you doing so many
barrel rolls that tom cruise is bound to
blush dogfight and fly through combat
zones set in an alternate history of
earth that'll have you flying through
the redwoods pacific northwest and
across oceans
[Music]
have you ever just looked at a raccoon
digging through your trash in the
backyard in the middle of the night and
thought to yourself man i bet that
raccoon would make a really good
detective yeah well me neither but the
developers at agnat maybe did and made
backbone a post noir narrative adventure
set in a dystopian vancouver inhabited
by suave talking animals and you play as
a raccoon not digging through trash but
being a sweet private eye unraveling a
deeply personal story inspired by old
school crpgs the game features elaborate
and in-depth dialogue systems with an
emphasis on exploration and environments
[Music]
keeping things classy let's talk about
empire of sin set in the criminal
underworld of 1920s prohibition era
chicago you take control of the city's
most historically infamous mobsters like
el capone and stephanie st clare in this
turn-based tactical strategy game you
gotta build and manage your criminal
empire and turn rival gangs into a bunch
of stiffs think xcom but with mobsters
and
well no aliens
and the last one which is really just a
personal favorite that i'm taking the
time to plug and well it's also last
because it's actually the only game on
this list that isn't available in the
cloud but i'm talking about grim
fandango you play as manny calavera a
grim reproposed travel agent that reaps
souls and sells them the best travel
packages to the land of eternal rest
it's an adventure game epic filled with
loads of mysteries spanning across the
afterlife it takes inspiration from
classic cinema like casablanca and
maltese falcon and it just so happens to
be my favorite game of all time so
there absolute shameless personal plug
for you to play a game that
means a lot to me
might to you maybe i don't know give it
a shot
can't hurt or yeah you can just keep
playing halo infinite and forza as long
as you're playing what makes you happy
that's all that matters no judgment here
alright that about does it make sure to
like and subscribe after all if you're
here it's because you like video games
and that's a thing we talk about in fact
that's all we talk about okay see you
later
[Music]
you